This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. About an hour east of Oakland in the town of Livermore, California, hanging in the garage of Fire Station number six. There's a small, pear-shaped light bulb. The light bulb is on. Right now, it's glowing,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在奥克兰以东约一小时车程的加利福尼亚州利弗莫尔镇，挂在六号消防站的车库里，有一只梨形的小灯泡。灯泡亮着。此刻，它正在发光，
and it's been glowing. It's just a couple of momentary interruptions for 113 years. Oh, there it is. We're looking at the longest burning, longest continuously burning light bulb in the world, and the Guinness Book of World Records, and it was installed in 1901. We send our producer Katie Mingle out there to see the bulb, which is a genuine heirloom from the dawn of electric illumination, built by one of its pioneers, a guy named Adolf
而且它一直都在发光。除了几次短暂的熄灭，它已经亮了113年。噢，就在那儿。我们看到的是世界上燃烧时间最长、持续燃烧时间最长的灯泡，它被载入了吉尼斯世界纪录，安装于1901年。我们派制作人凯蒂·明格尔去现场看看这只灯泡，它是电力照明黎明时期的真正传家宝，由其先驱之一，一个叫阿道夫的人制造，
Shalai. of electric illumination built by one of its pioneers, a guy named Adolf Schale. Probably when you think about the beginning of electric light, you go immediately to Thomas Edison. That's John Moellum, he's a writer from San Francisco. He wrote a piece about the Livermore Lightbowl for pop-up magazine earlier this year. But the age of electric light didn't just switch on all at once. You had tinkers trying to come up with better designs, trying to iterate and innovate, something that would burn longer or maybe brighter or that would cost less. So Shale was one of these guys. It was a great time of invention and innovation.
沙莱。电力照明的先驱之一，一个叫阿道夫·沙莱的人。当你想到电灯的起源时，你可能立刻会想到托马斯·爱迪生。那是约翰·莫勒姆，他是来自旧金山的一名作家。今年早些时候，他为《弹出杂志》写了一篇关于利弗莫尔灯泡的文章。但电灯时代并不是一下子就开启的。当时有许多修补匠试图提出更好的设计，试图迭代和创新，制造出能燃烧更久、更亮或成本更低的东西。所以沙莱就是其中之一。那是一个发明和创新的伟大时代。
All over America, light bulbs were going off over people's heads and some of those light bulbs were being turned into actual light bulbs. Shale liked to do this whole theatrical product demo where he'd take a big light bulb back, the kind you'd see on a theater marquee. In it would be one bulb of his own design and the rest would be bulbs from competing brands. Then Shalai would start slowly dialing up the power and one by one the competitors bulb all explode. Shalai's would be the last one shiny.
在全美国，人们的脑海中不断闪现出灵感，其中一些灵感被转化成了真正的灯泡。沙莱喜欢做这种戏剧性的产品演示，他会拿出一个大灯泡背板，就是你在剧院招牌上看到的那种。上面会装有一个他自己设计的灯泡，其余的则是竞争品牌的灯泡。然后沙莱会开始慢慢调高功率，竞争对手的灯泡会一个接一个地爆炸。沙莱的灯泡会是最后一个发光的。
One of those tenacious light bulbs made it all the way to Livermore, California. Its origin was in 1901 when a shop owner donated it to the town's volunteer fire department. They were called the fire boys in those days. And with the bulb hanging in their firehouse, this meant they could now gather up all their equipment if a call about a fire came in in the middle of the night in the dark. In those dark ages there were no fire engines. Firefighters used hose carts pulled by horses. Here's Tom Bramble, former deputy fire chief in Livermore. This tape of him is from a documentary about the ball called Century of Light. The volunteers that would that arrived to an incident they
其中一只顽强的灯泡一路来到了加利福尼亚州的利弗莫尔。它的起源是1901年，当时一位店主把它捐赠给了镇上的志愿消防队。在那个年代，他们被称为“消防男孩”。灯泡挂在他们的消防站里，这意味着如果半夜在黑暗中接到火警电话，他们现在可以集合所有的装备。在那个黑暗时代，没有消防车。消防员使用马拉的软管车。这是汤姆·布兰布尔，利弗莫尔前副消防局长。这段录音来自一部关于这只灯泡的纪录片，名为《光之世纪》。到达现场的志愿者们
would come to the station there and get their their hose cart, hitch up the horses, look for all of the equipment that they were looking for, but this light lit up the hose cart room so that it could without getting injured, falling over. So the light bulbs served a very significant function. In 1906, the fire station moved just down the street. The light bulb had been on at that point for five years. They had no idea how long it would last, but it was their only light bulb.
会来到车站，取他们的软管车，套上马匹，寻找他们需要的所有装备，但这盏灯照亮了软管车房，让他们不会受伤或摔倒。所以这只灯泡发挥了非常重要的作用。1906年，消防站搬到了街下。那时灯泡已经亮了五年了。他们不知道它能持续多久，但这是他们唯一的灯泡。
So of course, they brought it along. It seems like people just stopped thinking about the bulb after a while. There wasn't really an obvious way to shut it off, the way that it had been wired, but it must have just been dim and unobtrusive enough that no one really tried too hard. Eventually the old-fashioned hose carts were replaced with fire trucks. The bulb hung between the firehouses two garage doors and the firefighters were like aware of it, but they didn't think much about it. The bulb hung down, probably, well, hung down a pretty good distance from the ceiling and on a long cord that it actually sits on today, the same cord, but it was pretty it was low enough that you could walk by and actually reach up and tap the bulb and
所以当然，他们把它带上了。似乎过了一段时间，人们就不再关注这只灯泡了。由于它的接线方式，并没有明显的关灯方法，但它一定足够昏暗且不碍事，所以没人太费心去关它。最终，老式的软管车被消防车取代了。灯泡挂在消防站两个车库门之间，消防员们知道它的存在，但并没有太在意。灯泡垂下来，离天花板有一段相当长的距离，挂在一根长线上，今天它依然挂在那根线上，但它足够低，你可以走过去伸手拍拍它，
or just swing back and forth. As time went on we even would throw nerf balls at it. In 1971 the first full-time chief of the Livermore Fire Department, a guy named Jack Barard, got curious about the light bulb. And he asked a local newspaper reporter to look into the bulb's history. The resulting article got the residents of Livermore talking about the bulb, and it became a point to pride. Livermore's own little antiquity. The firefighters stopped throwing nerf balls at it.
或者让它来回摆动。随着时间的推移，我们甚至会向它扔泡沫球。1971年，利弗莫尔消防局的第一任全职局长，一个叫杰克·贝尔德的人，对这只灯泡产生了好奇。他请当地的一位报社记者调查灯泡的历史。由此产生的文章让利弗莫尔的居民开始谈论这只灯泡，它成为了一个骄傲的象征。利弗莫尔自己的小古董。消防员们不再向它扔泡沫球了。
Five years later, when the fire department was moving into a new building, they obviously knew that they couldn't leave the bulb behind and in fact Chief Beard insisted that they take it with them. On March 31, 1976, it was the day that we moved the light bulb from 2365 First Street out here on East Avenue to this station. That's Lynn Owens. He was the former division chief of the Livermore Fire Department. This interview was recorded for the Century of Light documentary released in 2011.
五年后，当消防局搬进新大楼时，他们显然知道不能把灯泡留下，事实上，贝尔德局长坚持要带上它。1976年3月31日，是我们把灯泡从第一街2365号搬到东大道这个车站的日子。那是林恩·欧文斯。他是利弗莫尔消防局的前部门主管。这次采访是为2011年发布的《光之世纪》纪录片录制的。
March 31st of 76 will always be a special day to me. The light bulb was escorted with red lights in a siren. We had a special box built. Not only that, but the box was painted red, which even made it more special. When they got the light bulb to the new station, the electrician set it up so that the light bulb could be screwed in immediately.
76年的3月31日对我来说永远是特别的一天。灯泡是在红灯和警笛的护送下搬运的。我们专门做了一个盒子。不仅如此，盒子还被漆成了红色，这让它显得更加特别。当他们把灯泡送到新车站时，电工把它装好，以便灯泡能立即拧上。
He climbed up the ladder with the light bulb, screwed the wires together so that everything would go on. And Frank, and made the connection, the light bulb didn't come on. And we gasped. Oh my gosh. Oh my goodness. What did we do? This world-famous light bulb, and now it's gone.
他带着灯泡爬上梯子，把电线拧在一起，以便一切都能通电。然后，连接好了，灯泡没亮。我们倒吸了一口凉气。天哪。噢，我的天。我们做了什么？这只世界闻名的灯泡，现在它坏了。
But then the electrician jiggled somewhere around. The light came back on. Everybody made a big sigh of relief. on. Everybody made a big sigh of relief. Mimo, as the light bulb was becoming more and more famous, it was impossible for people not to start wondering about what it was made of and how it could still possibly be working. The obvious way to solve the mystery would be to crack the light bulb open and examine it, but obviously no one wanted to do that. It was just too precious. Hi, I'm Deborah Katz. I'm a physics professor at the US Naval Academy in inapolis, Maryland.
但随后电工晃动了一下。灯又亮了。每个人都长舒了一口气。随着灯泡变得越来越出名，人们开始好奇它是由什么制成的，以及它怎么可能还在工作，这是不可避免的。解开这个谜团的显而易见的方法是撬开灯泡检查它，但显然没人想这样做。它太珍贵了。你好，我是黛博拉·卡茨。我是马里兰州安纳波利斯美国海军学院的物理学教授。
Dr. Katz did some tests on similar light bulbs. Light bulbs made by the same company in the same time period. She measured the thickness of the bulb's filament, which is that tiny piece of wire in the bulb that can break really easily. And I did that using a laser, so I didn't have to break the bulb to get in there. She figured out that the filament in the Livermore bulb was 8 times thicker than a regular bulb, and made from carbon instead of tungsten. What I figured out doesn't tell me why the filament shouldn't have broken by now. That's pretty incredible. I think it still is a mystery.
卡茨博士对类似的灯泡进行了一些测试。由同一家公司在同一时期制造的灯泡。她测量了灯泡灯丝的厚度，那是灯泡里那根极易断裂的小细丝。我用激光做了测量，所以我不需要打破灯泡就能进去。她发现利弗莫尔灯泡的灯丝比普通灯泡厚8倍，而且是由碳而不是钨制成的。我发现的结果并不能告诉我为什么灯丝到现在还没断。这真是太不可思议了。我认为这仍然是一个谜。
What she does know is that in 1924, a bunch of light bulb companies got together and formed a cartel called Phoebus. The goal of the cartel was for all the light bulb companies to stop making bulbs that lasted so long so that everyone could sell more light bulbs. Members of the cartel were actually charged fines if their bulbs burned for too many hours. And in two years, the companies light bulbs went from lasting 2,500 hours down to 1,500 hours. And by the 1940s, they actually made their goal of bulbs that only lasted 1,000 hours. The Shelby Company, which manufactured Chile's bulb, had already gone out of business by the
她所知道的是，1924年，一群灯泡公司联合起来成立了一个名为“福玻斯”的卡特尔。卡特尔的目标是让所有灯泡公司停止制造寿命那么长的灯泡，这样每个人都能卖出更多的灯泡。如果成员公司的灯泡燃烧时间过长，他们实际上会被罚款。两年内，这些公司的灯泡寿命从2500小时下降到了1500小时。到了20世纪40年代，他们实际上实现了灯泡寿命仅为1000小时的目标。制造沙莱灯泡的谢尔比公司在
time the FEMA's cartel had been formed. But I'd like to think that they wouldn't have been involved with that nonsense. I think they were trying to make a quality product rather than a product with built-in obsolescence. And a quality product it was. This whole time, of course, the bulb was just hanging there and continuing to glow. So in a way, its story was taking on this air of magical realism. In 2001, a group of locals decided to live
福玻斯卡特尔成立时就已经倒闭了。但我愿意相信他们不会参与那种胡闹。我认为他们是在努力制造高质量的产品，而不是带有内置报废机制的产品。它确实是一个高质量的产品。当然，这段时间里，灯泡一直挂在那里继续发光。所以从某种意义上说，它的故事带上了一种魔幻现实主义的色彩。2001年，一群当地人决定为利弗莫尔
or more ought to have a hundredth birthday party for the light bulb. They formed the Centennial Bulb Committee and started planning what they thought would be a small get together at the firehouse that June. In the end, 600 people showed up and they had cake and there were rock bands playing and kids dancing on the top of the fire truck.
举办一场灯泡百岁生日派对。他们成立了百年灯泡委员会，并开始计划他们认为会在那年六月在消防站举行的小型聚会。最终，600人到场，他们吃了蛋糕，有摇滚乐队演奏，孩子们在消防车顶上跳舞。
Committee members gave live interviews to Katie Kurek and CNN. By then responsibility for the bulb had passed from chief bearer, he was the first fireman to become interested in the bulb, to one of the firefighters who served under him, Lynn Owens, you heard from him earlier. Owens had been one of the younger guys in the seventies
委员会成员接受了凯蒂·库里克和CNN的现场采访。到那时，灯泡的责任已经从贝尔德局长（他是第一个对灯泡感兴趣的消防员）转移到了他手下的一名消防员林恩·欧文斯身上，你之前听过他的讲述。欧文斯是七十年代那些年轻人中的一员，
who'd sat around checking Nerf footballs at the light bulb. But by this point, by the time the bulb turned 100, he was already a retired division chief. He was the screening aging guy with these tiny glasses and a bristly white mustache. Owens loved the bulb. And he left to reclaim his love. That light bulb is dependable. That light bulb has been doing the job it was intended to do since 1901. It was like he was talking about the light bulb the way James Earl Jones talked about baseball at the end of field of dreams.
他们曾坐在那儿向灯泡扔泡沫球。但到了这个时候，当灯泡满100岁时，他已经是一位退休的部门主管了。他是一个头发花白、戴着小眼镜、留着硬白胡子的男人。欧文斯热爱这只灯泡。他热爱重申他的爱。那只灯泡是可靠的。那只灯泡自1901年以来一直在履行它预定的职责。他谈论灯泡的方式就像詹姆斯·厄尔·琼斯在《梦幻之地》结尾谈论棒球一样。
It reminds us all that once was good. It could be again. Actually, that's how a lot of people end up talking about the light bulb though. People write letters to the committee and they say things like the light bulb gives them hope, or they call it, quote, a reassuring reminder of faithfulness and service. In a letter, President George W. Bush called the light bulb, quote, an enduring symbol of the American spirit of invention, end quote. For a lot of people, it also ironically symbolizes another great American invention, planned obsolescence.
它提醒我们所有人，曾经美好的事物，可以再次美好。事实上，很多谈论灯泡的人最终都是这样说的。人们给委员会写信，说灯泡给了他们希望，或者称它为“忠诚与服务的令人安心的提醒”。乔治·W·布什总统在信中称这只灯泡为“美国发明精神的持久象征”。对许多人来说，讽刺的是，它也象征着另一项伟大的美国发明：计划报废。
I like the light bulb because it's this little speck of continuity. You know, it's something that started more than a century ago, and it keeps going. So it sort of connects us to that time. You can almost imagine it like this little ember of a campfire that was lit back then, and is still glowing. And it kind of in the same way, if you trace that history, you see these waves of people coming together around that fire and then slowly leaving the picture and new ones coming in.
我喜欢这只灯泡，因为它是一个小小的连续性象征。你知道，它是从一个多世纪前开始的，而且它一直在持续。所以它在某种程度上把我们与那个时代联系起来。你几乎可以把它想象成当时点燃的营火中那一点余烬，至今仍在发光。以同样的方式，如果你追溯那段历史，你会看到一波又一波的人聚集在那堆火周围，然后慢慢离开画面，新的人又加入进来。
The Lightbulb outlived Jack Baird, the first fire chief who became curious about it, and Lynn Owens, its most devoted caretaker. Shalais Lightbulb has seen generations of firefighters come and go through Livermore. So in 2001, right around the time of the party, the Centennial Bulb Committee also set up a webcam in front of the light bulb. The camera takes a picture of the bulb every 30 seconds so that people all over the world can make sure that it's still on. The guy who maintains the camera is named Steve Bunn. And he told me he's already had to replace the supposedly high-tech webcam two times because the light bulb has outlasted both of those devices. The bulb has its own standby generator, something inaccurately named the
这只灯泡比杰克·贝尔德（第一个对它产生好奇的消防局长）和林恩·欧文斯（它最忠诚的看护人）活得更久。沙莱的灯泡见证了利弗莫尔一代又一代消防员的来来去去。所以2001年，就在派对前后，百年灯泡委员会还在灯泡前安装了一个网络摄像头。摄像头每30秒拍摄一张灯泡的照片，这样全世界的人都可以确认它是否还在亮着。维护摄像头的人叫史蒂夫·邦恩。他告诉我，他已经不得不更换了两次所谓的“高科技”网络摄像头，因为灯泡的寿命比这两个设备都长。灯泡有自己的备用发电机，一种被不准确地称为
uninterruptible power supply. It's zonked out suddenly in the middle of the night in May of 2013. And when it did, the light bulb went dark. Steve told me that when it happened, people around the world who happened to be watching the webcam at that point saw the bulb link out and started calling or emailing him panicked or just in disbelief. The bulb was out for nine hours and 42 minutes before someone was finally able to get over to the firehouse and rake up an extension court. When it was turned back on, Steve said, everyone swore it looked brighter. She's into us To die by your side
“不间断电源”的东西。它在2013年5月的一个深夜突然断电了。当它断电时，灯泡熄灭了。史蒂夫告诉我，当这件事发生时，全世界当时正在观看网络摄像头的观众看到灯泡熄灭，开始惊慌失措地打电话或发邮件给他，或者只是感到难以置信。灯泡熄灭了9小时42分钟，直到有人最终能够赶到消防站并接上延长线。当它重新开启时，史蒂夫说，每个人都发誓它看起来更亮了。她对我们说，死在你身边
It's such a heavenly way to die Under the tuntum shore Kill the foe of the bones To die by your side Well, the measure that infringes mine Oh, well, the legend never goes out 99% Invisible was produced this week by John Moellum and Katie Mangle with Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Christopher Lepp, who allowed us to use audio from his film Sentry of Light.
这是一种多么神圣的死亡方式，在坦坦海岸下，杀死骨头的敌人，死在你身边，好吧，那侵犯我的尺度，噢，好吧，传说永不熄灭。《99%隐形》本周由约翰·莫勒姆和凯蒂·明格尔制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马斯参与。特别感谢克里斯托弗·莱普，他允许我们使用他电影《光之世纪》中的音频。
You can find a link to the film on our website. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW in San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of Arkson, an architecture and interiors firm located in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Let's stay safe downtown Oakland, California. Let's stay safe out there, everyone. You can find 99% invisible and like us on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, everyone's this killer Tumblr for us, but for links and pictures and lists of songs
你可以在我们的网站上找到这部电影的链接。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Arkson建筑与室内设计公司办公室制作。大家在外要保持安全。你可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并点赞，我在Twitter上是@RomanMars，每个人都为我们制作了这个很棒的Tumblr，但要获取链接、图片和歌曲列表
and all the back episodes, go to 999pi.org. Radyo Tepi from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及所有过往剧集，请访问999pi.org。来自PRX的Radyo Tepi。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。